por qué
[Música]
y
esta semana se cumplen 100 días del
inicio de la invasión de rusia al
territorio ucraniano según indicó el
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selenski
las tropas rusas ya controlan el 20 por
ciento del territorio de su país con
posiciones muy avanzadas en el este del
territorio ucraniano escuchemos a día de
hoy casi el 20 por ciento de nuestro
territorio está bajo el control de los
ocupantes casi 125 mil kilómetros
cuadrados casi 300.000 kilómetros
cuadrados están contaminados con minas y
municiones sin explotar casi 12 millones
de ucranianos se convirtieron en
desplazados internos entre ellos más de
5 millones principalmente mujeres y
niños que se fueron al exilio es tal vez
uno de los anuncios más importantes de
la semana también entre otros hechos
destacados a lo largo de los últimos
siete días están ocurriendo diferentes
hechos en la ciudad de severodonezk que
ya está prácticamente en manos de las
tropas rusas cerca del 70% del
territorio ya está en manos de los
militares rusos también destacado a lo
largo de esta semana las fuerzas
ucranianas siguen resistiendo la
ofensiva rusa en buena parte gracias a
la que ha sido donado por países
europeos y también por eeuu
de hecho la más reciente donación de
washington a kiev corresponde a un
avanzado sistema de cohetes que busca
reforzar la posición defensiva de las
tropas ucranianas precisamente en el
este del país en la zona del donbass se
trata de los m 142 and mars una unidad
móvil que puede lanzar múltiples misiles
guiados con alta precisión y de largo
recorrido
desde moscú indicaron que esto podría
provocar una confrontación con occidente
estas son las palabras del canciller
ruso sérguei lávrov otra de los
comentarios destacados de la semana
escucharlos
estos riesgos ciertamente existen las
cosas que el régimen de quien exige sin
remordimientos de sus patrocinadores
occidentales
en primer lugar sobrepasan todos los
límites de la decencia y las relaciones
diplomáticas y en segundo lugar son una
provocación directa destinada a llevar a
occidente al combate
de otra parte la unión europea impulsó
también una nueva ronda de sanciones
contra rusia esta vez busca reducir las
importaciones de petróleo ruso hasta en
un 90 por ciento en un plazo que va
hasta final de este año también
destacada esta semana la medida que deja
pues por fuera a hungría a eslovaquia ya
la república checa- estoy hablando de
este veto al petróleo ruso porque son
países que no tienen salida al mar y es
específicamente para el suministro de
petróleo que llega a través de
gasoductos a través del mar estos países
son fuertemente
del petróleo ruso y seguirán recibiendo
otro tipo de abastecimiento a través de
los gasoductos y oleoductos
terrestres bruselas también acordó
enviar 9 mil 700 millones de dólares a
kiev para ayudar a mantener la economía
ucraniana seriamente afectada por esta
guerra ya son cerca de 22 millones de
toneladas de cereales que no pueden ser
exportadas por ucrania lo que ha
desatado también un encarecimiento de
los granos y de los cereales a nivel
mundial
ya incluso se habla de una crisis
alimentaria en un futuro que podría
afectar fuertemente a la región de
américa latina' un tema que analizamos
aquí en este programa pero bueno quedan
varias preguntas entonces para analizar
de acuerdo a los hechos más recientes
hay en ucrania el nuevo tramo de
sanciones de la unión europea que
impacto va a tener esto en rusia y en su
industria petrolera y como entender la
posición y las consecuencias de las
acciones que ha dado un país en el
centro de europa muy particular hungría
con el envío de las baterías de misiles
a ucrania que son enviadas desde eeuu
para reforzar esa estrategia está eeuu
un poco tentando a rusia esto que costó
va a implicar para washington va a
provocar una reacción en moscú varias
autoridades en la ciudad de kiev también
han dicho que la capital ucraniana es
nuevamente el blanco siguiente para
conquistar por parte de los rusos que
tan cierto puede ser esto el 20 por
ciento del territorio ucraniano como ya
lo decíamos está en manos de los rusos
esto significa que selenski y las tropas
están perdiendo terreno como ven son
muchas las preguntas que tenemos para el
programa de hoy a raíz de todos los
hechos recientes pues las vamos a
analizar por lo menos a tratar de ver
las más importantes y para analizar este
tema saludamos a añadir a gálvez
salvadores ya es profesora investigadora
en el centro de relaciones
internacionales de la facultad de
ciencias políticas y sociales de la
universidad nacional autonoma de mexico
ella se encuentra precisamente en la
ciudad de mexico la capital de la
república mexicana y aquí en el estudio
de france 24 nos acompaña jean marie
chino ls profesor de ciencia política y
estudios globales de la universidad de
los andes que está ubicada en la ciudad
de bogotá en colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden hacer parte
de esta conversación los invito para que
dejen los comentarios y las preguntas
que tengan al respecto en nuestras redes
sociales ya lo saben estamos en facebook
en instagram en twitter también pueden
ver nuestra señal en streaming en
youtube no se encuentran como france24
s sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
entre 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios
entonces para que ustedes participen en
este programa comienza entonces dándole
la bienvenida a yadira gracias por
acompañarnos y conectarse desde la
ciudad de méxico- yadira y punto de
partida como me gusta llamar alá la
pregunta para abrir el debate cien días
se cumple esta semana desde el inicio de
la invasión de rusia el kremlin contaba
que dice iba a demorar tanto tiempo para
poder conquistar el territorio ucraniano
los ucranianos han demostrado tener una
fuerza de resistencia mayor que la que
los rusos esperaban la comunidad
internacional también esperaba que esta
guerra se fuera extender tanto tiempo
como lo vio usted
hola santiago gracias por la invitación
y coincido con los puntos que acabas de
poner en la mesa de discusión sobre el
par de los círculos del kremlin
el primero habían dicho que no iba a
haber tal invasión y que solamente están
haciendo la serie de ejercicios
bielorrusia vino la intervención y todo
parece indicar que el cambio no había
calculado una intervención rápida en la
cual encontrará poca resistencia y
también me parece que estaban apostando
a la falta de unidad porque los países
europeos y eeuu respecto a la respuesta
frente a esta invasión una cuenta
también de círculos sobre el resistencia
dañan a las posibilidades de control del
territorio y hemos visto como
gradualmente han ido orientando la
estrategia en qué sentido como primero
fue una estrategia abierta incluyendo el
tema de editar y tratar de para quién y
lo redujeron es a los objetivos
estratégicos que plantearon ellos de
esta región de bombas pero sí que se ha
alargado que ha traído múltiples
consecuencias de carácter humanitario
que cambia por supuesto la dinámica la
seguridad y la gente política europea y
pues estamos viendo cómo evoluciona y te
parece todo parece indicar que va a ser
además una guerra que todavía vamos a
estar presenciando por mucho tiempo más
derivado de esto de la oposición sucia
orientada a garantizar su permanencia
ahí pero también la resistencia por
parte de fran ya santiago y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 la de la bienvenida
a llamar y gracias por acompañarnos hoy
a compararlos acá en el estudio y bueno
la misma pregunta como el punto de
partida 100 días había expectativa que
esto fuera a ser un poco más corto esto
se va a prolongar y vemos que en los
últimos días sobre todo la ofensiva rusa
se ha recrudecido sobre todo en el este
del país sí muchas gracias por la
invitación santiago es cierto que se
preveía una guerra corta breve no fue el
caso pero parece que rusia tiene un plan
b y el plan de es incrementar la guerra
en el donbass controlar el sur del país
un corredor ruso hacia crimea entonces
esos elementos todavía están en juego y
también cambiar la perspectiva de los
países aliados de ucrania ya en la unión
europea o eeuu que al principio tenían
de reticencia de ayudar de apoyar a
ucrania con 12 veía que de que iba a ser
una derrota rápida pero ya que se ve que
hay resistencia por parte de ucrania y
una posibilidad de que la guerra siga
por lo menos todo este año ya hay un
apoyo mucho más fuerte a través de
sanciones de envío de armas etcétera
llamar y continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda a la inversa veíamos las
palabras del presidente es el script 20%
del territorio ucraniano ya está en
manos de los rusos no solamente en la
región del donbass también vemos avances
importantes en la costa del mar negro la
región de gerzón también muy cerca al
puerto de mariupol y la ciudad de sap
orilla donde hay una importante planta
nuclear de hecho la más grande de europa
que ucrania ya está contemplando la
posibilidad de desactivarla precisamente
por el asedio ruso está a ucrania
perdiendo terreno ante la avanzada rusa
como lo puede analizar usted
pues el movimiento es mucho más lento y
lo que dicen los expertos es que vamos a
pasar de una guerra de movimiento a una
guerra de posición que después de tres
meses de guerra los ejércitos están
cansados llegaron a cierto límite a
nivel logístico y entonces si han ganado
terreno 20 por ciento del territorio
ucraniano no es cualquier cosa pero es
probable que no haya avances tan rápidos
como los vimos en las primeras semanas
de la guerra o incluso contra ataques
tan rápidos por parte de las fuerzas
ucranianas como lo hemos visto en algún
momento probablemente se van a
consolidar esos territorios conquistados
por rusia y se va a consolidar también
la resistencia ucraniana en ciertos
puntos muy específicos
guerra de posiciones como usted lo ha
definido eso lo podemos ver
ejemplificado en hace dos semanas
hablábamos del gran asedio a la ciudad
de mariupol ese puerto y la
fábrica industrial que había allí un
punto importante para la resistencia
esta semana el foco ha estado en
severodonezk independientes y sea una
ciudad estratégico no pues es una de las
acciones grandes ucranianas mariupol era
un puerto finalmente tiene valor
estratégico pero estos van a ser digamos
los movimientos de los rusos ir un paso
conquistar una ciudad y eso puede estar
ligado a esas denuncias que hacen desde
kiev que dicen que la capital puede ser
el siguiente objetivo
parece ser la estrategia de rusia tomar
unas ciudades pero esas ciudades están
ubicadas en sitios estratégicos para el
nuevo plan de rusia que no es conquistar
a toda ucrania no llegar a la capital no
cambiar el régimen ucraniano como tal
sino tener presencia fuerte en el
oriente del país en el sur del país
controlar el acceso al mar y en parece
que estás en ciudades estratégicas ya no
son jr ya no son ciudades del norte del
país sino en ciudades del oriente y del
sur del país retomamos la conexión con
nuestra invitada con la vida en ciudad
de méxico- yadira estábamos hablando con
jean-marie precisamente de ese 20% del
territorio ucraniano que ya está en
manos de las fuerzas militares rusas él
le preguntaba jean-marie si esto nos da
la sensación que ucrania está empezando
a tener terre a perder terreno ante el
avance lento como nos ha dicho el
invitado en el estudio de las tropas
rusas pero es un avance lento pero
certero tal parece
es un avance que ha sido gradual y rusia
ha ido configurando su estrategia con la
finalidad precisamente de hacerse de
estos espacios de terreno y hacer un
corredor listo para la conexión con la
zona precisamente de crimea y controlar
todas estas áreas que son de carácter
estratégico para nada para la lógica y
para mí y para precisamente el
posicionamiento de rusia ahora bien esto
que ha señalado el presidente félix y
sobre el control del 20 por ciento del
territorio el por supuesto que alerta en
el sentido de que él está haciendo un
llamado para fortalecer el apoyo de la
comunidad internacional por un lado y
por otro también se da cuenta de que
esta es la estrategia o craneano a
finalmente está de cierta forma
orientada muchísimo a la resistencia y a
tratar de contener como bien lo dijo el
colega comercial en la palabra maría
láriz yo llamaría el poder vamos a estar
viendo esta dinámica y por supuesto que
rusia cada que da un da un paso al
frente pues ellos lo ubican como una
arteria en términos tanto narrativos
como por parte de los ultras quien está
jugando a ganar lo más que pueda en el
sentido de tener más capacidades en la
nueva afición y por supuesto que es él
el que también quiere tener una posición
de fortaleza y ha dicho que no va a
permitir que el cráneo pierda soberanía
sobre ti torrico y pesa y también van a
estar enfrentadas las negociaciones y es
que en algún momento que vuelve a matar
yadira en cuanto a lo que usted menciona
de los posicionamientos territoriales
sea perder la soberanía como lo dice el
presidente se leyó la menciona varias
veces ya se ha contemplado la
posibilidad que en las regiones de
gerzón en lugansk y antonieta se lleven
a cabo un referendo similar al que hubo
en crimea en 2014 para mirar si los
ciudadanos aceptan o no una
incorporación de estos territorios a la
federación de rusia esto que cuánta
validez puede tener esto siendo unos
territorios que están ocupados en este
momento no están bajo la soberanía total
de ucrania y esto la luz del derecho
internacional y para la comunidad
internacional
de representar esto para rusia
sí por supuesto
rusia ha apostado desde el inicio de
este conflicto como gran en particular a
señalar que y es lo que argumentan que
parte de ésta en realidad la
intervención tiene que ver con la
protección de los ciudadanos
pronunció y lo hizo una ciudadanía que
está en esta zona y quiere repetir la
fórmula se usó anteriormente respecto al
tema de los de llamarnos a una
habitación en torno al pero el tema acá
es que como puede ser válida una
habitación de eso natural es un
ejercicio de esa naturaleza cuando
estamos hablando de una intervención
militar en el país es decir en términos
de derecho internacional rusia está
violentando la soberanía de ucrania de
utilizar la fuerza para llevar adelante
esta intervención 1 y 2 no tendría por
qué
el válido de este tipo de ejercicios en
la medida precisamente que se están
dando en un contexto de intervención
entonces aceptó participar muchísimas
controversias pero a mi parecer no
tendría una validez en este tipo de
ejercicios porque estamos hablando de un
ejercicio que se hace en un marco de una
intervención de un marco de lucha de la
costa y el nombre desde una perspectiva
rusa de la protección de los ciudadanos
que eso de verdad que no justifica el
uso de la fuerza en relaciones
internacionales y la intervención es
algo que hemos venido debatiendo durante
todo el sector nos italia
controversia se refiere yadira en torno
a lo que puede generar este tipo de
consultas en estas tres regiones y esas
controversias pueden llevar a
discrepancias por ejemplo con la unión
europea que recientemente impuso un
sexto paquete de sanciones la unión
europea le sigue apostando a esta
fórmula de sancionar antes que tener
presencia militar allí y enfocarse en
eso y en la ayuda humanitaria para los
ucranianos que salen del país qué tan
efectivo ha sido ésta ha sido esta
fórmula para la unión europea
pues las sanciones en general en la
historia de las relaciones internaciones
no son no tienen eficacia vamos a ver
por qué es cierto que generalmente las
sanciones son más tímidas y vemos una
evolución de las sanciones europeas que
al principio le apuntaban a sectores que
no afectaban mucho a la economía europea
no quería incluir el gas no quieren
incluir el petróleo y estamos viendo que
hay un cambio de posición por parte de
la unión europea una posición mucho más
firme en las sanciones que si van a
afectar la economía rusa por lo menos en
las relaciones económicas entre rusia y
la unión en la unión europea hay que ver
ahora si rusia tiene la posibilidad de
reemplazar a esos socios comerciales
europeos por ejemplo con china y si va a
haber una reconfiguración del comercio a
nivel internacional que le permita a
rusia mantener una política ilegal a
nivel internacional sancionada por rusia
por la por la unión europea perdón
sancionada por eeuu pero no tan
criticada por parte de china o de la
india aquí ha habido varios puntos
importantes dentro de este último tramo
de sanciones por parte de la unión
europea primero ese veto a un porcentaje
de importación de petróleo procedente de
rusia petróleo que llega a través de
gasoductos que está oleoductos perdón
que llegan a través del mar en este caso
el mar báltico que llegan a través del
mar negro eso para poder salvar a países
que dependen del petróleo ruso como
hungría eslovaquia y república checa-
que lo veíamos acá esto inmediatamente
puede generar problemas en la economía
rusa dada la rapidez con que están
implantando estas sanciones porque ya
bruselas dijo de aquí a final de año el
90 por ciento del petróleo ruso se deja
de importar esto puede provocar un
colapso económico en el país va a tener
consecuencias económicas fuertes en
rusia pero en el mundo en general y es
ahí donde queda el problema de las
sanciones las sanciones afectan
obviamente al régimen agresor en este
caso a rusia pero también a la economía
global lo vamos a ver con los alimentos
con la energía con los fertilizantes
entonces vamos a tener consecuencias en
el mundo entero de unas sanciones que
están previstas para rusia en particular
eso sí la rapidez de las sanciones
pueden afectar a rusia y no darle el
tiempo de mirar a otros socios porque
probablemente esa relación con china se
va a fortalecer pero eso va a tomar
tiempo y mientras tanto rusia va a
sufrir con esas sanciones yadira
seguimos conectados con usted por vía
telefónica si no estoy mal porque hay
problemas con su imagen o algunos
problemas con el vídeo pero continuamos
con usted quiero preguntarle por un país
que ha tenido un rol muy particular
desde el inicio de esta invasión y es
hungría
ha sido uno de los países que digamos le
pone un poco de piedras en el camino a
la hora de tomar decisiones a la unión
europea pero tendrá sus argumentos y su
posición para hacerlo en este caso es su
dependencia del petróleo que viene de
rusia el gobierno húngaro en budapest
dijo que le tomaría años puede
reemplazar a rusia como su principal
país para suministrar el petróleo ahora
vemos que ha logrado
una negociación con bruselas como
entiende uno la forma actuar de hungría
está actuando en su beneficio o esto es
de verdad una evidencia de esa relación
que pueda haber entre viktor orbán y
putin
sin duda él
el papel de los baños ha sido un papel
que tenemos que entender en la propia
lógica de sus el desarrollo de sus
intereses nacionales en este sentido
bona urban no es un aliado
no no no no juega dentro de la unión
europea a partir de la lógica de
acompañar todas las iniciativas de la
unión tiene que estar buscando estos
equilibrios a partir esto de la relación
con rusia que mantiene de su propia
proyección de capacidades políticas y
lectoras
del propio de todos estos problemas que
había también con la unión europea
respecto a las secciones de libertades
democráticas de la propia característica
de su régimen pero de una manera muy
pragmática no ha hecho ningún paso que
es lo que los paquetes de canciones que
se han aprobado hasta ahora lo que sí ha
hecho por ejemplo es editar en esta
semana que éste para que transacciones
llegará por ejemplo al papel que debe
ser todo lo que está haciendo es
mantener o tratar de mantener un
equilibrio entre la lógica de su
proyecto político con la relación con
rusia con la relación común europea y
justo hungría puede ser un punto de
quiebre respecto a la posición común de
los europeos hay futuras no hay una
fractura todavía dentro de la unión
europea pero conforme vayan avanzando y
pase el tiempo y avance los
y las sanciones y también
avancen los problemas económicos que
puede llegar a tener la unión por el
alza en los precios del combustible
vamos a ver también este tipo de
complicaciones al interior de la unión
que por cierto hay que decirlo no van a
aceptar ningún tema de también el sesión
de soberanía por parte del cráneo
ampliado
es que hay que decir que hungría en esta
reciente negociación logró que la unión
europea sacara de su lista de personas
sancionadas económicamente y de sus
cuentas en europa al patriarca kiril que
es el jefe de la cabeza de la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa hay grietas en la unión
europea desde hungría como lo vio usted
llamar y siempre ha habido grietas en la
unión europea en la época de la invasión
de irak en la época de cuando se
discutía la idea de de fortalecer una
defensa de la unión europea siempre hay
una grieta entre unos países del oriente
de europa que confían más en eeuu que en
la misma unión europea en términos de
defensa frente particularmente a rusia
hay una grieta entre democracias y
países cuya democracia está desmejorando
rápidamente como es el caso de hungría
entonces hay muchas grietas y en el caso
de hungría hay también una grieta
cultural religiosa con ciertos países de
la unión europea y con los países que
ven a rusia como un país lejano
culturalmente
pasemos ahora a otra de las
controversias de la semana yadira y es
ese anuncio de eeuu de enviar un
digamos unos equipos de misiles que le
permitiría a ucrania hacer
ataques de alta precisión y a larga
distancia esto puso muy nervioso al
kremlin porque ya ucrania podría atacar
directamente desde su territorio
diferentes posiciones estratégicas en el
territorio de la federación más allá de
lo que implica esto en el combate diario
'el ya que lo dijo que lo usaré
simplemente para defensa esto como tensa
la relación entre washington y moscú
moscú ya dijo esto va a generar
problemas
y por supuesto esto todavía le agrega un
elemento más de atención a la relación
entre washington y moscú en eeuu ha
dicho el presidente bailén ha dicho que
este apoyo ha militado gracia tiene como
objetivo fortalecer las capacidades del
país y apoyarlo en la resistencia frente
a la interrupción y try han estado
pidiendo
constantemente este tipo de armamento
se trata de una decisión estratégica en
el sentido de acompañar lo que se ha
definido como la cia lógica para
afrontar a rusia en la parte diplomática
la cuarta depresión económica y el apoyo
a ucrania que desde la perspectiva en
eeuu lo que fortalece fortalezas gracias
pero desde la perspectiva de rusia
implica una incorporación a una
participación más fuerte de eeuu en el
conflicto tanto estados unidos como la
otan de manera pragmática van a seguir
apoyando a rusia a las perdonamos a
ucrania de manera
estratégica pero no van a tener un
enfrentamiento directo con rusia lo que
está haciendo la otan lo que está
haciendo estados unidos es fortalecer
las capacidades ucraniana evitando un
enfrentamiento directo con rusia y en
una lógica también la habituación
fortaleciendo a los aliados de la otan
de europa del este con mayor exposición
al equipo de washington efe está pero
usted menciona que tal vez esto implica
que eeuu se ve un poco más comprometido
en la guerra esto quiere decir eeuu está
cambiando su estrategia para este
conflicto como lo analiza usted
pero no es que estados unidos está
cambiando los procesos del conflicto
sino que están decidiendo mantener el
apoyo a ucrania y fortalecer sus
capacidades y eeuu se ha mantenido en la
misma lógica de yo creo que apoyar sin
generar un paso más allá pero creo que
está muy comprometido en este momento
para rusia está unidad está directamente
interviniendo en el conflicto y parece
que tenemos que entender también qué
clase de conflicto estamos librando
porque es un conflicto que se está
librando en distintos ámbitos presenta
el cristo también que lleva a las
sanciones económicas que tiene que ver
con el manejo de la información y por
supuesto que el apoyo a ucrania que es
un tema de sistema de seguridad que hace
eeuu y que hacen los aliados de la otan
dejan de apoyar al gran interés de rusia
avanza o en realidad mantienen su
compromiso y fortalecen esas capacidades
pero el problema es que nos va a llevar
esto a que la guerra
luego a prolongarse mucho más lo que
eeuu es fortalecer a ucrania para que
este país tenga un mayor nivel y
capacidad de llegar a la negociación
anuncia
pero con todas estas implicaciones
creo que está fortaleciendo el papel a
nivel militar llevar a rusia a una
posible negociación esta puede ser una
de las reacciones que pueda tener moscú
a raíz de esta de este anuncio de
washington a un país tan impredecible
como rusia es un juego muy peligroso me
parece porque sí es cierto que puede
fortalecer a la resistencia ucraniana y
llevar a rusia a tener que sentarse en
la mesa de negociación puede ser una
consecuencia pero puede ser visto y ya
hay declaraciones en ese sentido como
una agresión como una un compromiso
demasiado fuerte de eeuu con las fuerzas
de resistencia ucranianas y eso puede
escalar entonces ahí es un juego
peligroso porque la narrativa de rusia
como agresor y ucrania como víctima no
tiene o sea es muy sólida a nivel
internacional en este momento pero sobre
todo sólida en europa y en eeuu mucho
menos en el sur global mucho menos en la
india mucho menos en china etcétera
entonces le conviene a eeuu que se
mantenga un conflicto con un poco más
equilibrado entre y rúsia para poder
llegar a una negociación pero al mismo
tiempo puede ser visto desde otras
partes del mundo como un involucramiento
directo de eeuu en un conflicto que no
le corresponde entendiendo entonces esa
forma de actuar de washington de la
casablanca y la respuesta dada por el
canciller ruso que también veíamos las
imágenes acá y veíamos sus declaraciones
esto puede generar un enfrenta un nuevo
enfrentamiento con occidente esto
entonces como lo podemos entender
tratando de entender la lógica rusa un
reconocimiento del conflicto en ucrania
o un nuevo escenario en otra parte no se
puede descartar por completo un nuevo
escenario del conflicto entre rusia
occidente pero lo más probable es que se
quede en ucrania porque ya vemos que ha
sido difícil para rusia cuando
intentaron llegar a kiev a la capital
directamente no lo lograron ahora están
en el oriente del país con cierta en
ciertos éxitos militares estratégicos
pero con pérdidas pero con dificultades
logísticas entonces no se puede imaginar
tu creo que incluso para un régimen tan
poco predecible como el de vladimir
putin no se puede imaginar
enfrentamiento en otro escenario creo
que rusia no tiene esa capacidad pero si
un estancamiento en rusia y una incluso
una escala con google ucra miento cada
vez más directo de eeuu y los países
occidentales no es deseable para la paz
mundial sí y cuando hablo de otro
escenario enfrentamiento no
necesariamente me estoy refiriendo a un
país que vaya a ser un tercer país para
un conflicto sino que también estamos
hablando de decidido ciberataques o algo
en cuanto al sistema financiero de eeuu
otro tipo de seis esferas o también en
la esfera informática que ya hemos visto
que pues también allí se está librando
una batalla de desinformación tanto en
el lado de occidente como el lado de
rusia aquí lo hemos analizado también en
el programa punto importante también
para ver dentro de los anuncios de esta
semana yadira fue ese ese comunicado de
prensa que presentó la acnur a nivel
mundial diciendo que la cifra de
desplazados de ucrania hacia diferentes
países de europa y del mundo ya supera
los 6 millones y convierte a la crisis
humanitaria de ucrania en la peor crisis
humanitaria a nivel global en este
momento en la actualidad incluso
superando a la situación actual en siria
cuanto más puede resistir a europa esta
llegada masiva de ucranianos a través de
las fronteras de la unión europea el
primer país de escala polonia que es el
que más ha recibido a ucrania nos
escapando de la guerra
por tanto hasta ahora han sido una
política de acogida
amplísima muy orientada justo a los
brazos abiertos para acoger
fundamentalmente a los niños a las
mujeres que están saliendo de ucrania
parecido a representar un problema de
mediano y largo plazo en cuanto a cómo
se va a atender cómo cómo van a mantener
a estas personas cómo se van a integrar
a las comunidades y nos lleva también al
debate sobre la diferencia en cómo se ha
atendido esta crisis de los refugiados
de ucrania y otra crisis no
particularmente por la crisis de los
refugiados
precisamente de siria como que comenta
que se ha señalado pues el doble rasero
significa en este momento que en estos
momentos del mundo abiertos frente al
refugio de las personas que vienen de
ucrania y lo que sucedió en otros en
otros momentos particularmente con el
caso de clientes si es y me parece que
decir es un reto para la unión europea
en el mediano y en el largo plazo el
tema de cómo van a mantener estas
capacidades de acogida en un contexto
que se antoja un hito muy incierto y con
precisamente como tema llamar y especial
que te puede escalar el conflicto a
partir de el envío de armamento por
parte de eeuu y por supuesto que en la
escalada o el mantenimiento del
conflicto santiago además que esta
crisis humanitaria pasa no solamente por
ese más de 6 millones de ucranianos que
ya lograron salir del país sino también
que otros 8 millones de ucranianos se
han desplazado internamente para poder
salvar sus vidas sobre todo del este
hacia el oeste del país debido al
conflicto impresiones por este lado ya
mari de la crisis humanitaria lo que ha
representado para europa recibirá toda
esta cantidad de ucranianas
pues es una cuestión de voluntad
política la unión europa tiene la
capacidad económica estamos hablando de
los países entre los países más ricos
del mundo tienen la voluntad política
por ahora entonces se puede hacer pues
muchas regiones del mundo viven con
flujos de refugiados estuvimos aquí la
la ola de venezolanos hace unos años en
el medio oriente en áfrica
desplazamientos masivos de población se
dan en las relaciones internacionales en
diferentes regiones del mundo es el caso
en europa ya ha pasado históricamente en
europa pero yo creo que si tienen la
capacidad económica y parece que existe
la voluntad política entonces mientras
esas dos condiciones están reunidas
puede haber una ayuda humanitaria a esas
poblaciones desplazadas por parte de la
unión europea en tal política y brazos
abiertos que no hubo para los sirios que
estaban intentando llegaran a polonia
atrás de la frontera con belarús ahí si
las condiciones fueron completamente
diferentes muchas críticas cayeron sobre
polonia y la unión europea en ese
momento me quedan ya pocos minutos para
terminar el programa quiero cerrar con
otro de los anuncios importantes de la
semana 22 millones de toneladas de
cereales ucranianos
represados sin poder ser exportados y el
mundo entero con en algunos puntos
desabastecimiento o encarecimiento de
los de los precios lo analizamos aquí en
este programa esa posible crisis
humanitaria o alimentaria perdón a la
que puede llegar a américa latina que
estamos muy lejos de la realidad
ucraniana pero nos va a golpear de una u
otra forma
putin ha dicho que va a liberar los
puertos esto puede ser un algo que se
pueda tener en cuenta como algo positivo
por parte de rusia para abastecer al
mundo si bien parece que no va a haber
negociación por ahora en términos de
llegar al final del conflicto a
soluciones territoriales si puede haber
negociaciones para la salida de esos
alimentos de ser real principalmente en
la onu está tratando de mediar en este
sentido y la idea es que puedan salir
porque si puede darse una crisis
alimentaria en el resto del mundo tal
vez a américa latina es más un
encarecimiento por el tema de los
fertilizantes mientras que en el norte
de áfrica donde se consume mucho trigo
digamos y el vínculo la relación y la
crisis puede ser mucho más directa
yadira le pregunto ahora por un país es
importante en esta negociación también
precisamente con el tema de los puertos
para permitir salir los barcos desde los
puertos ucranianos que están en poder de
los rusos y es turquía país que tiene
que dar paso a través del estrecho del
bósforo y de los dardanelos para salir
al mediterráneo y al mundo turquía tal
vez se ha retirado un poco de ese
impulso que tuvo como un país mediador
ofreció a ankara y estambul para hacer
el escenario de una conversación entre
selenski y putin o entre los cancilleres
y ahora se le nota un poco más
concentrado en su tema con suecia y
finlandia que piensan entrar a la otan
sí absolutamente que si está concentrado
en el tema de las negociaciones de la
entrada de todos países a la otan justo
utilizando sus intereses nacionales
respecto a sus propietarios es que
turquía señala en cuanto a el apellido
que decía tenía que decir países
lagartos en la resistencia de los
serbios y esto se potencia a tomar un
papel muy importante y es enap es
importante para lograr que la otan
afecte el ingreso de islandia y suecia
en está en estas en estas negociaciones
y por esto te perdonándonos ahora como
está enfocado a lograr estos objetivos y
bueno también tenemos que tenemos que
entender que turquía que si puedes jugar
un papel importante en cuanto a la
mediación pero que también está tratando
de proyectar esta es paciente a meter a
poco menos de un minuto para las
conclusiones ya dirá que podemos ver en
los próximos días en este conflicto que
movimientos que fichas a nivel político
se pueden mover cuál es su análisis
pero también aparece que estados unidos
y los socios de la otan van a seguir
apostando por fortalecer las capacidades
militares de ucrania sin tener una
intervención directa en el conflicto
aunque como señalamos bien por rusia
señalarte u2 se identifica que esto ya
significa un escalamiento del mismo que
pueda mostrar que no vamos a mantener la
lógica de la atención a nivel
internacional si lo podemos seguir
iniciando con esta dinámica de
identificar las piezas que rusia va a
seguir moviendo en el tablero del plan
gracias a iraqiya no hay 20 segundos
para la conclusión si no no soy muy
optimista a corto plazo probablemente
esa crisis humanitaria va a seguir los
hilos en las batallas también en el
terreno entonces probablemente no vamos
a llegar a una negociación en los
próximos las próximas semanas o incluso
los próximos meses entonces nada el
panorama no nada como para mucho
optimismo muchas gracias a llamar y
añadir a en la ciudad de mexico por
haberse conectado desde la capital
mexicana de llamar y por estar con
nosotros aquí en el estudio france24 de
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 en toda américa
latina ustedes puede seguir en ciento
con la información en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]